Guten Morgen Linos.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sieht's aus? Wir haben wir haben äh den Bond erreicht.
Ja die Bondfolge.
Null null sieben von Logbuch Netzpolitik versucht äh einzuleiten, was äh.
Alles so geschehen ist in der letzten Woche und man kann sich ja nicht äh beklagen an äh Neuigkeiten.
Halt wieder nicht. Also wir haben ja gerade im Vorgespräch schon so ein bisschen sortiert. Es gibt immer viel Neues, vielleicht müssen wir das demnächst hier täglich machen.
Da müssen wir uns aber umbenennen, den Tagebuch.
Web-Logb-Buch Netzpolitik.
Oha, na ja, das äh soweit sind wir noch nicht. Aber vielleicht mal so zu Beginn noch eine etwas internes ähm,
ich habe mir die Mühe gemacht, die letzten Folgen dann auch noch mal nachträglich mit Kapitelmarken zu versehen und habe mir auch vorgenommen, jetzt künftig alle Sendungen auch mit Kapitelmarken zu veröffentlichen,
Das war mir eigentlich von Anfang an ein Anliegen, aber es äh kam nicht so recht dazu. Das ist ja ein nicht ganz unerheblicher Zusatzaufwand, der aber hier geleistet werden soll, um einfach auch die Nachschlagefähigkeit hier in diesem Podcast zu,
verbessern, weil wir werden zunehmend äh in die Situation kommen
darauf verweisen, dass wir ja schon mal über irgendwas gesprochen haben und das ist natürlich viel einfacher, wenn man sich eine alte Folge runterladen kann und dann springt man eben mal so auf diese Diskussion, die da in den Kapitelmarken schon drin steht
So soll es sein und so wird es hier jetzt auch sein und alles wird gut.
Also nochmal alle durchhören bitte kurz und gucken, ob die Kapitelmarken richtig gesetzt.
Genau, ja ich äh lasse mir da auch eines Besseren äh belehren, weil ich habe mir ein bisschen Mühe gegeben und ich werde es auch für die ersten drei zugegebener Zeit dann äh auch nochmal nachholen. Ja.
Was ist passiert? Wir fangen äh mal mit den Kurznachrichten an, dachten wir uns, bevor wir uns dann gegen Ende mehr den längeren Themen widmen, anders als wir es das letzte Mal gemacht haben.
Erste Meldung, die wir in der Hinsicht beleuchten wollen, sind die Hermes-Bürgschaften der Bundesregierung.
Das kennt auch nicht jeder.
Genau, Hermes Bürgschaft, ganz interessante äh ganz interessantes Ding. Ähm kann man sich bei Wikipedia auch nochmal genau anschauen, was das ist. Da,
also um den Außenhandel zu beflügeln sorgt die versichert, die Bundesregierung den Handel mit irgendwelchen unsicheren Vertragspartnern.
Also kann sie machen. Und ähm quasi um irgendwie den also die die.
Was heißt mit unsicheren Vertragspartnern? Also sie bietet quasi eine Versicherung für diese Firmen, falls denen die Kunden weglaufen.
Also sie versichert Exportkredite. Also die Bundesregierung ähm äh garantiert für Exportkredite, um denjenigen, die etwas exportieren wollen, den Mut zu geben, das auch zu tun.
Also es stellt sicher, dass die Banken auch bei solchen,
Risiko behafteten Geschäften, wo die Bank befürchten muss, dass die äh erwartete Einnahme ausfällt, da haftet dann quasi der Staat und sagt, mach das mal, das ist schon gut. Wir äh setzen hier das Risiko auf äh äh null oder zumindest in einen
äh kalkulierbaren Bereich und passt schon.
Also die Schutz, sie schützen die unter die deutschen Unternehmen vor Verlusten durch ausbleibende Zahlungen ihrer ausländischen Geschäftspartner. Zahlt der ausländische Abnehmer nicht, springt der deutsche Staat ein.
Das haben sie irgendwie erstmals neunzehnhundertneunundvierzig gemacht äh für die heutige Eule Hermes Kreditversicherungs AG. Ähm.
Ebenfalls unfirmierte PWC AG ähm irgendwie mit solchen ähm Exportkreditgarantien beauftragt.
Und deswegen heißen die heute noch Hermes Deckung oder Hermes-Bürgschaften.
So dass ähm klar also der Effekt dessen ist, also es gibt natürlich mehrere Risiken, gegen die sie irgendwie äh versichern, also was weiß ich nicht, Zahlungsfall
was weiß ich, ich äh schicke meine Überwachungstechniken nach Syrien, aber die ähm füllen nicht den Überweisungsträger aus, wenn das Paket angekommen ist oder sie gehen irgendwie in,
äh Konkurs oder in die Zwangsvollstreckung oder politische Risiken gibt's natürlich auch äh kriegerische Ereignisse, Revolutionen äh und gegen all das kann man sich also versichern.
Das rundum sorglos Paket,
Ihrer Bundesregierung. Jetzt hast du es ja schon angedeutet, also grundsätzlich ist das ja auch ein Ziel und ich denke, wenn jetzt hier äh eine Firma äh äh Brunnenbautechnologie äh in Entwicklungsländer
schicken will und sich da versichert, da finden wir das irgendwie ganz toll, aber was halt jetzt auch bekannt geworden ist, ist das natürlich auch
diese sehr umstrittene Überwachungstechnologie, die unter anderem eben auch in Deutschland hergestellt und eben auch exportiert wird, auch von diesen Hermes-Bürgschaften abgedeckt wird.
Genau und zwar geht das zurück auf eine ähm kleine Anfrage.
Da muss ich jetzt leider mal so ein bisschen also auf dem Blog Grün digital einen Artikel, den ich auch verlinke und der ist leider so ein bisschen ähm bisschen wirre geschrieben.
Aber da wird das alles so drin geschildert, dass sie also Ende März eine Anfrage gestellt haben. Jetzt ist aber nicht raus klar erkenntlich, wer das jetzt genau war, aber wahrscheinlich dann Konstantin von Notz und Malte Schmitz würde ich jetzt mal tippen ähm,
Aber es steht hier leider unter dem Beitrag auch nicht drunter, also hier mal kleines
Nee, ist von Konstantin von Notzia Artikel, also hat er da, hat er denn wahrscheinlich diese Anfrage wahrscheinlich auch erstellt und dann kam irgendwie ihre ihrer, da fragten sie dann eben, wie wie das so ist mit den sogenannten Gütern, also nämlich diese Überwachungstechnologie, gilt als,
also ein ein Gut, was was zweierlei Nutzung zugeführt werden kann. Man könnte damit also quasi ähm.
Nicht militärisch, zivil irgendwie einfach ein Kommunikationsnetz betreiben, also diese Überwachungsfunktionen sind ja in fertige,
Kommunikationsgeräte eingebaut. Das heißt, ich kaufe mir jetzt nicht ein zusätzliches Überwachungsmodul zu meinem Kommunikationsnetzgerät, sondern ich kaufe mir ein Kommunikationsnetzgerät mit Überwachungsmodul,
und dadurch wird das offensichtlich als kein problematischer Export gesehen. Und ja, alles andere dazu verlinken wir einfach, weil,
Uns heute erstmal noch anderen Themen, anderen Themen zuwenden wollen.
Genau, wir wollen uns äh zum Beispiel äh Facebook zuwenden, ist ja immer ein sehr dankbares Thema, wenn's um äh Pleiten, Pech und Pannen geht. Ja. In diesem Fall gab's eine schöne Datenlücke bei Facebook.
Genau, man konnte bei Facebook irgendwie ein Bild markieren als also man hat sich irgendwo so ein Bild angeschaut von einer Person, hat gesagt, dieses Bild ist irgendwie zu reporten, das ist irgendwie obszön,
Und wenn, dann bietet einem Facebook an, zu sagen, zeig uns doch mal, willst du uns nicht helfen, vielleicht noch weitere Bilder von dieser Person als obszön zu markieren, um zu schauen, ob
vielleicht einfach das nur ein einmaliger Ausrutscher war oder ob vielleicht diese ganze Person nicht in Ordnung ist. Und wenn man dann gesagt hat, ja, dann zeigte Facebook einem alle Bilder dieser Person, unter anderem,
eben auch die als privat markierten Bilder. Schöner Back und äh wurde dadurch wurden dann auch direkt irgendwie privat Bilder von Mark.
Zuckerberg aus dem Facebook rausgeholt.
Und ich hoffe auch als obszön markiert.
Ja, musste man ja dafür irgendwie machen. Dadurch ist es ihn wahrscheinlich aufgefallen.
Ja, haben sie natürlich dann schnell behoben. Sagt eigentlich auch nicht sehr viel mehr aus, als das äh so und äh man kann noch so viel sich Mühe geben, am Ende ähm,
muss nur aus der Null einer Eins werden und schon,
die Sache einfach dahin, also es zeigt einfach, dass man sich eben nicht drauf verlassen kann, dass was wirklich privat bleibt. In dem Moment, wo es den eigenen Kontrollbereich verlässt, ist es potenziell öffentlich.
Gut, äh was haben wir noch?
Joah, Delfinverleih hatte sich irgendwie entschieden, man könnte doch mal den Film Sonnenallee auf YouTube veröffentlichen, aus welchen Überlegungen heraus sie das auch immer getan haben, nach kürzester Zeit war er gesperrt.
Ist das jetzt auch der äh rechte Eigener.
Genau, also der der Filmverleih war, der äh ist die die hatten das Recht, das zu tun.
Und offensichtlich ähm haben sie's also warum auch immer sie sich dazu entschieden haben, wollten also diesen gesamten Film Sonnenallee haben sie selber auf YouTube draufgestellt und haben gesagt, den kann man sich jetzt da angucken. Ist ein Komödie von Leander Hausmann, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
und ähm ja nach kurzer Zeit, dann waren natürlich erstmal alle so ha hier toll, ne, Film im im auf YouTube und nach kürzester Zeit war er dann gesperrt.
Und keiner wollt's gewesen sein, es stand aber groß drauf, dieses Video enthält Content von Sony Music Entertainment und ist deshalb in deinem Land nicht verfügbar. Was natürlich doof ist, wenn er in Deutschland nicht verfügbar ist, weil der Film ja dann doch sich an eine deutsche
Zielgruppe richtet.
Ähm es stellte sich aber so, man findet also nicht wirklich heraus, keiner hat dann irgendwie den Finger hochgehoben und hat gesagt, hier ich war's. Und es allen Anschein nach sind da die automatischen,
die automatischen Kontrollfilter von YouTube angeschlagen. Die ja irgendwie,
Algorithmen haben, Content zu erkennen, der.
Dem Fall auch Musik.
In diesem Fall auch Musik und dann scheint also irgendwo in dem Film Sonnenallee irgendein Lied, dessen Rechte bei Sony Music liegen. Äh vorhanden zu sein und automatisch per YouTube das dann.
Also ein schöner Auswuchs, so einer automatischen.
Stellt sich mir natürlich die Frage, welche Rechte hat äh der Filmverleih oder der Filmhersteller, der Produzent in dem Moment,
im Hinblick auf eine Veröffentlichung des Films im Netz kaufen, die für so einen Film die Rechte so weit ab, dass das dann,
wirklich egal ist, wie sie das distributieren oder gibt es eben im Hinblick auf die Musiklizenzierung, zumindest auf die Musiklizenzierung von Sony, da noch Einschränkungen?
Das ist äh sehr gut denkbar, dass es die vielleicht tatsächlich gegeben hat, ja. Also da soweit äh wurde in dem in den Artikeln, die ich dazu gelesen habe, die natürlich eher alle so ein bisschen hämisch waren. Äh soweit wurde darauf nicht eingegangen.
Na ja, ich meine, da muss man,
schon beleuchten, ne? Ist das jetzt quasi ein Vergehen des Filmverleihs gewesen, weil sie tatsächlich diese Rechte dafür jetzt gar nicht so gehabt hätten, nur davon ausgingen, dass sie sie hätten? Oder ist es wirklich nur so eine äh dumme, automatische Blockierung?
Dazwischen kam nach dem Motto, ach hier so die Musik darf nirgendswo sein, beziehungsweise nur da, wo irgendwie das entsprechende Bit-Gesetz ist und zwar von Sony und das ist hier nicht erfolgt
Also zeigt auf jeden Fall, dass diese Systeme funktionieren.
Genau, also was möglich wäre,
vielleicht auch, was das du gerade sagtest, vielleicht hat Sony auch einfach echt selber gesehen, hat gesagt, Moment mal, unser Vertrag mit euch sieht nicht vor, dass ihr das irgendwie auf YouTube ballert,
Und äh deswegen sperren wir das jetzt äh aber auch dann wäre es natürlich irgendwie verständlich, dass keine der beiden Seiten sich irgendwie weiter zu dem Sachverhalt geäußert hat. Also das
Video war nach kürzester Zeit wieder oder nach einigen Stunden wieder erreichbar und.
Jetzt ist es online.
Jetzt ist es offensichtlich online, ja?
Super. Na dann könnt ihr euch das jetzt alle äh mal angucken.
Genau, ganz witziger Film.
Ja, eine Nachricht, äh die schon ein bisschen älter ist, dass sie uns so ein bisschen äh unter unserem Radar äh sich bewegt hat, dreht sich um das von uns ja schon lange angekündigte Thema acta.
Wo wir immer sagen, das legen wir ad acta an.
Genau. Auch dieses Mal, trotzdem ist es, glaube ich, wert zu erwähnen, dass das holländische Parlament sich äh äh quasi für eine,
Offenlegung von acta ausgesprochen hat, beziehungsweise wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, abgelehnt hat, sich äh damit zu befassen oder das einfach als Realität anzuerkennen, solange da nicht klar ist, worüber da verhandelt wird.
Genau, also,
es wurde jetzt irgendwie von der EU-Kommission ratifiziert, jetzt muss das EU-Parlament zustimmen und die Mitgliedstaaten. Und jetzt legen die dieses Geheimabkommen dann offensichtlich diesen Parlamenten vor.
Und sagen aber, das ist geheim,
Also Sie, Sie können sich das irgendwie, was weiß ich, im Dunkelkämmerchen dann mit nachher Rucksackkontrolle irgendwie anschauen, aber dürfen mit niemandem großartig darüber reden. Und jetzt haben äh hat das niederländische Parlament gesagt, also ähm so machen wir das nicht,
wir können nicht über diese Sache beraten, ernsthaft, wir können nicht mit, wenn wir nicht mit Experten darüber sprechen, noch äh die Öffentlichkeit über die Konsequenzen dieses Abkommens unterrichten dürfen.
Also es ist das ist wirklich so hanebüchen, dieser diese ActA Geschichte. Also allein schon die Prämisse, ja, dass man da einen internationalen Vertrag macht.
Und man will nicht darüber reden. Man man also, was bitte ist denn da die die gesetzliche Grundlage oder auch nur die moralische.
Ja, Legitimation für so ein Vorgehen, also das wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Es ist völlig verrückt. Also sie müssen sogar so ein NDA, also ein Non-Disc Clausur-Gream unterzeichnen, ja.
Ja, wenn man das also irgendwie prüfen möchte, müssen sie äh, dass sie schriftlich müssen sie schriftlich verpflichten, weder im Parlamentsdebatten, auf Dokumente zu verweisen, noch daraus zu zitieren.
Also völlig,
Irrsinnig, egal, was das ist. Und wenn das jetzt der Friedensvertrag für die Welt wäre, äh ist völlig unverständlich, dass irgendwie so eine Menge an Ländern, so einen Vertrag schließen soll, der bis zu seinem Schluss,
völlig unter Verschluss bleibt. Ich frage mich, ob die überhaupt der Nachveröffentlichen wollen. Vielleicht wollen die Akte ja nie veröffentlichen.
Man wird dann einfach verhaftet auf Basis eines Gesetzes, was wir ihnen leider nicht zeigen können, weil äh das ist äh kann man ihnen nicht sagen, ja. Also das ist das ist einfach Kafka. Also das hätte sich jetzt Kafka auch nicht besser einfallen lassen können so.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass es dann irgendwann schon äh mal öffentlich werden soll, dieser Vertrag, aber ähm also man fragt sich wirklich, was was da gehen einem wirklich einfach geht einem nur noch der Mund auf.
Aber es ist schon so ein bisschen prozessartig, so dieses, ja, was was ist mir denn vorzuwerfen? Jetzt können wir Ihnen nicht sagen, sind Sie jetzt erstmal verhaftet.
Niederländisches Parlament zeigt er auf jeden Fall.
Genau, also wir werden äh Acta sicherlich nochmal genauer behandeln, das war auf jeden Fall eine interessante Sache und es äh spricht sicherlich auch nichts dagegen, auch den anderen Parlamenten mal ein bisschen in die Arschbacke zu kneifen, um ihnen klar zu machen, dass das einfach das richtige Verhalten ist. Ich meine, das kann man jetzt bei aller Neutralität,
einfach mal sagen.
Das äh das ist das ist ja auch denke ich einfach mal das das Gebot äh unserer Zeit, ja? Ich meine, die Piraten haben insofern da,
Transparenz glaube ich auch.
Setzen sie auch einfach auf das Interessanteste äh äh Pferd derzeit, wo sich einfach auch eine breite Öffentlichkeit nicht nur anschließen könnte, sondern auch anschließt, dass es eigentlich vielen Leuten
völlig gegen den Strich geht
dieses ganze geheim verhandeln und dieses ganze äh eben im stillen Kämmerchen Getue. Man sieht ja auch, dass das einfach die die Quelle für äh
Korruption und äh Dinge äh äh sind, die einfach äh den Schaden an der Öffentlichkeit da wirklich vorantreiben.
Und da ist natürlich das auch auf so einem internationalen Level einfach nur abzulehnen.
Also, wie gesagt, bei Aktie die inhaltliche Kritik ist schon stark, war aber was die prozedurale Kritik in dem Fall angeht. Also.
Übersteigt das sogar noch.
Das ist kaum noch. Also es ist in keiner Form noch irgendwie zu rechtfertigen.
Ja, letzte Woche äh haben wir noch gerätselt, wie es denn so beim SPD Parteitag zugegangen ist. Wir haben das Ganze an einem Montag aufgenommen. Da lief der Parteitag noch. Und insbesondere war die.
Nicht mit großer Spannung erwartete, aber noch zumindest ausstehende Entscheidungen über das Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Stand aus, wurde auch mehrfach nach hinten verlegt und ich glaube, es ist dann auch an dem Montag gar nicht mehr behandelt worden, sondern erst am Dienstag.
Was ist denn nun rausgekommen?
Ja, gab's flammende Reden von allen möglichen Leuten und am Ende wurde über wurde dieser.
Sie von uns ja auch schon kritisierte Antrag mit einer knappen Mehrheit angenommen, der eben darauf lautet, Datenschutz
zu gewährleisten, indem man die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eindämmt. Das heißt, es gibt kein Bekenntnis der SPD laut.
Parteitagsbeschluss gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sondern dafür in abgeschwächter Form.
Was eigentlich den,
Status Quo jetzt äh verschlimmert, weil darüber hatten wir ja kurz gesprochen, du meintest ja na dann würde ja quasi der bisherige Beschluss stehen, wenn ich äh mittlerweile richtig unterrichtet wurde
Gibt es in dem Sinne einen solchen Beschluss bislang ja noch überhaupt nicht, zumindest nicht von der Partei
Also es wurde bisher auf dem Parteitag noch nichts beschlossen. Es gab quasi eine de facto Linie, die äh von der Fraktion beziehungsweise damals eben der Regierung auch gefahren wurde, ähm wo sie ja
letzten Endes auch beschlossen haben,
Noah hat die Partei als solche dazu noch nicht geäußert. Insofern ist es eben jetzt eine Verschlimmbesserung ähm des Zustandes, weil jetzt gibt es eben eine Äußerung der Parteibasis.
Angeblich und die besagt so, na ja äh.
Also es gibt jetzt, es gibt einfach einen Parteitagsbeschluss, ja? Also das ist ganz und damit haben wir jetzt nominell ähm wenn ich das richtig zähle, eine große Mehrheit für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung im,
Parlament sitzen. Also wenn die, wenn die CDU könnte,
morgen mit der SPD die Vorratsdatenspeicherung wieder einführen, vorausgesetzt, dass die Leute, die auch von der SPD Bundestagsfraktion, da setzen sich irgendwie an diesem
Parteitagsbeschluss halten. Und das fand ich ja schon sehr witzig ähm dass also
Ei war Freude, der ja auch SPD solidarisch ist. Ähm antwortete dann auf meine äh Bemerkung zu diesem Vorfall auf Twitter. Das wäre ja schließlich nur ein äh Parteitagsbeschluss. Und äh also da habe ich,
Okay, ich meine, vielleicht kenne ich mich da nicht so genau mit den Gepflogenheiten der SPD aus und äh vielleicht ist in der Tat ähm gibt's da andere Dinge, die irgendwie überwiegen.
Aber ähm offizielle Linie SPD ist jetzt pro Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Also, wenn das so unbedeutend wäre, frage ich mich, warum es überhaupt so viel Druck gab. Äh diese Variante durchzudrücken, wo es doch äh eine große Mehrheit von ablehnenden äh Vorschlägen gab.
Also worauf dennoch verwiesen wurde, ist, dass also die Leute, die tatsächlich aus der Bundestagsfraktion waren, das von die Mehrheit dieser Sprecher sich gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgesprochen hat.
Ob das aber auch die Mehrheit der Fraktion im Zweifelsfall äh darstellt, dass äh.
Das werden wir dann erleben.
Das wird sich dann vielleicht zeigen, ne. Also mein erster Gedanke war ähm.
In der Piratenbasis können sich jetzt schon mal ein paar die Krawatte gerade ziehen und äh schon mal äh ihre Lebensplanung überprüfen, ob sie nicht in zwei Jahren für äh vier Jahre mal was anderes tun wollen, als sie es jetzt tun.
Das ist irgendwie also weiter kann man das Türchen ja fast gar nicht öffnen.
Naja, sie haben ja noch den Leitantrag Freiheit, Gerechtigkeit und Solidarität in der digitalen Gesellschaft,
äh über den wurde mit überragender Mehrheit also für den wurde mit überragender Mehrheit abgestimmt. Der wurde über eine Adhocrissy Plattform in Kooperation mit über sechshundert Internetnutzern erstellt. Att hoc Racy sind also diese
Liquid Feedback zu betitelnden Abstimmungstools, die so aus dem Bereich.
Heißt das. Konzept Liquid Feedback ist die eine. Ist eine andere äh Implementierung. Ja, das muss man immer wieder klarkriegen.
Absolut äh richtig und wichtig, also so eine eine offene, kollaborative Entscheidungsfindungsplattform könnte man Atforcy, glaube ich, nennen, oder?
Ich kenne ad hoc selber nicht besonders gut. Ich habe eine CAE gemacht zu Liquid Feedback, da ging's wirklich in jedes Detail äh hier und da klang auch Unterschiede an zu Air Tocy, die kann ich aber jetzt nicht mehr äh
kriege ich jetzt so aus der Erinnerung nicht, äh zuverlässig zusammengefegt. Es gibt halt bestimmte Unterschiede
Und ähm bei den Piraten ist Liquid Feedback halt mittlerweile einfach das System geworden und findet ja auch.
Zunehmenden Maße Zuspruch, weil jetzt ist natürlich gerade mit der Berliner Fraktion
aber auch so mit dem insgesamten Wandel, so wie ich den beobachte, der Piratenpartei einfach die Zustimmung zur Verwendung solcher Tools insbesondere äh im Hinblick auf die Vorbereitung von Parteitagen, das hat sich, glaube ich, auch beim letzten Parteitag sehr positiv,
wirkt also steigt die Zustimmung und die Annahme solcher Werkzeuge. Inwieweit das bei der SPD jetzt wirklich,
Was aussagt, ich meine, das Schwierige bei solchen Liquid Demogressy Sachen, insbesondere, wenn sie eben mit Delegation arbeiten und ich will mir jetzt gerade der doch, es müsste eigentlich bei auch mit drin sein, weil das ist ja eigentlich eine Kernidee. Bei Liquid Democracy, dass man eben.
Unbedingt zu allem eine Meinung hat, sondern dass man eben seine Meinung auch delegieren kann. Dass man eben sagt.
Zwar zu verschiedenen Personen, zu verschiedenen.
Genau, andere, die für mich ähm also andere, von denen ich der Meinung bin, dass sie im Prinzip meine Linie entsprechen, das aber irgendwie besser verstehen und da auch im Detail besser abstimmen und verhandeln können, sollen für diesen einen Bereich,
Meinung dann eben vertreten. Ich kann das jederzeit auch wieder rückgängig machen. Ich kann jederzeit diese Delegation entziehen. Dadurch kriege ich das eben was Dynamisches oder
eben flüssiges, was das ist ja eigentlich das, was in dem Namen Liquid Democracy drinsteht, das ist einfach eine sehr flüssige Geschichte ist, da kann das Wasser in die eine Richtung ausschlagen, aber es kann sich auch genauso schnell wieder zurückziehen und entsprechende,
Strömungen, äh dadurch eben vertreten.
Und äh jetzt heißt es hier sechshundert Leute wurden da äh genommen. Das Problem ist, dass solche.
Wir haben sechshundert Leute gefragt.
Ja, dass dass solche Systeme äh wie soll ich sagen, also in dem Moment, wo man eine Beschlussfindung macht,
ist es relativ wichtig, eine eine scharfkantige Definition der Entscheidungsgruppe zu haben.
Wenn man jetzt einfach irgendwelche Leute nimmt, wo dann auch beliebige Leute einfach dazustoßen können, ist es eben nicht mehr in dem selben Maße repräsentativ, als wenn man eben jetzt wirklich sagt,
die Fraktion, die Mitglieder, ja,
Ist auch schon eine schwierige Geschichte, weil man kann ja schnell Mitglied werden in so einer Partei, et cetera. Aber ähm umso äh umso schärfer eigentlich auch so ein
so eine Gruppe definiert ist und abgesteckt ist
Ja, die kann nicht jederzeit dann beliebig anwachsen und die sind alle irgendwie involviert und die haben alle irgendwie ein Interesse und die müssen sich auch in gewisser Hinsicht irgendwie positionieren. An der Stelle wird es halt wirklich spannend, deswegen finde ich eigentlich grundsätzlich
da interessant, wo man eben wohl abgesteckte äh äh Gruppen hat, die eben versuchen, sich über irgendwas äh einig zu werden. Jetzt ist das schön, dass die SPD damit
ähm experimentiert. Ich frage mich halt nur, wer sind jetzt diese sechshundert Internetnutzer
Ja, also äh was sagt das aus diese Gruppe? Wer wer ist da jetzt mit drin und Internetnutzer kenne ich eine Menge? Das ist für mich jetzt sozusagen ein bisschen unklar, ähm was es ist. Trotz alledem,
kann ich mir vorstellen, kann ich mir vorstellen,
Westgeist ist diese sechshundert Internetnutzer sind, nämlich die Leute, die einfach jetzt mal Bock haben, sich auf der Basis da für SPD, Meinungsbildung auch einzusetzen,
ähm am Ende ist natürlich die Frage, was kam bei raus? Was kam dabei raus?
Ja, was haben wir, also so,
eher so Forderungen, die wir auch, zum Beispiel, als wir über den Parteitagsbeschluss der Grünen da gesprochen haben, so ein bisschen mit drin hatten, also Universaldienstverpflichtungen,
Also, wie bei Strom und ähm Wasser äh bleibt es nicht mehr der Überlegung des Anbieters, der den wirtschaftlichen Überlegungen des Anbieters überlassen, ob er jetzt in die hinterste Pampa,
Kabellicht oder nicht, sondern das muss er einfach machen. Ähm man möchte auch so eine kommunale, öffentliche, kostenlose WLAN-Infrast.
Eine eine ganz alte Forderung von mir, die sich eigentlich mehr auf Hotels bezieht, aber die man gerne auf die äh Gesellschaft erweitern kann. Stromwasser, Internet.
Stromwasser-Internet, das ist einfach, ja, wenn du in Hotelzimmer gehst, dann, und dann gehst du davon aus, dass du da Strom hast und du gehst davon aus, dass du äh Wasser hast,
und zwar Flatrate. Du zahlst für das Zimmer,
und du hast dann keinen Strom, Gebühr und die ersten drei Kilowatt sind frei und danach zahlst du äh auch mal zwanzig Euro pro Kilowatt oder so oder ja sie können irgendwie zwei Minuten lang duschen und danach,
Temperatur, ja, das macht einfach keiner. Aber im Internet wird es eben so gemacht und das muss äh ein Ende finden und ich finde es schön, dass dieser Gedanke sich eben jetzt auch auf das Gesamtangebot für die Gesellschaft äh.
Ich werde deine Hotelforderung noch um Bett erweitern.
Der ja gut, ich meine, im Bett ist ja, sagen wir mal, das Kernding, was man eigentlich kauft. Ja, also wenn wenn irgendwas wirklich sich nicht von dem Angebot Hotel trennen lässt, dann ist es ja ein Bett,
aber äh du kriegst halt in der Regel Strom noch dazu. Ich meine, du könntest ja theoretisch auch ein Hotelzimmer anbieten, ohne Strom.
Strom zwei Euro.
Ja, ginge.
Oder auch ohne, na, also Wasser ist dann schon ein bisschen schwieriger so, weil Klo, ne, würde man ja schon auch irgendwie denken, aber wenn man jetzt mal so Jugendherbergen oder sowas äh äh denkt, da ist das ja auch nicht unbedingt immer aufm Zimmer
Ja und jetzt müssen wir halt so die Jugendherberge Bundesrepublik Deutschland uns halt einfach mal ein bisschen denken, so was, was, was muss halt da drin sein?
Jugendherberge Deutschland hat also laut SPD dann demnächst ähm Medienkompetenz als Pflichtteil, jeden Lehrplans, also auch eine sehr vage Forderung. Man solle auch mehr Crowd-Sourcing und Schwarmintelligenz nutzen,
Open Data und offene Haushalte findet man auch gut
man müsse Bürokratiearme, Mikrokredite zur Förderung einer Internetgründerkultur geben, ja? Also wollen sie auch irgendwie ähm dass da mehr
in wirtschaftlichen Bereich passiert, eine gesonderte Alterssicherung für Solo-Selbstständige, also ähm.
Denn Solo-Selbstständiger.
Solo-Selbstständige sind äh es wird das, was man als das ähm moderne Präkariat bezeichnet oder die die digitale Bohem.
Lerne ich meine, welcher Selbstständige ist ja nicht solo.
Weiß ich nicht, aber heißt halt so, also stand da so, ich meine ähm ich.
Ja, also ein Solo-Selbstständiger ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie ein wie ein Pulsschlag oder.
Es macht ja aber jetzt nicht unverheiratet oder so.
Gehe ich nicht von aus, nee, also wahrscheinlich heißt es einfach nur quasi diese Arbeitskraftunternehmer. Ja, also ich AGs oder also äh quasi,
Podcaster, die sich von Auftrag zu Auftrag hangeln und äh ihre also Arbeitskraftunternehmer wird das, glaube ich, ganz gerne auch genannt.
So was ist ein interessanter Punkt. Ähm es gab vor ein paar Tagen, ich weiß nicht, ob du's gesehen hast, auch einen äh eine Wortmeldung von Juli C.
Ja, die ist doch auch in.
Die sich ja schon sehr lange äh in diesem äh Freiheitsbereich auch bewegt, auch die hatte ich ja mal in einem,
CRI Podcast, sehr schöne Sendung, zusammen mit dem Ilja Treuerdorf, mit dem sie gemeinsam dieses Buch geschrieben hat und ähm,
Sie hat sich konkret jetzt nochmal so zu den Gründen, warum denn das mit den äh Piraten überhaupt so gut funktioniert, geäußert? Und äh,
quasi auch ein paar Empfehlungen gegeben,
Worauf man sich denn jetzt irgendwie stürzen sollte, unter anderem eben auch auf die äh Situation von Selbstständigen. Was ich insofern sehr interessant finde, weil das ja auch ein altes Thema der FDP ist.
Ja, also in der FDP fühlten sich
als Wählergruppe unter anderem auch die Selbstständigen angesprochen, weil die Volksparteien deren Sicht es doch im Wesentlichen so von Arbeitnehmerarbeitgeber Verhältnissen geprä
besonders bei der SPD, aber eben auch bei der äh CDU, ja, schlagen es mehr in die Arbeitgeber oder mehr in die Arbeitnehmer äh Richtung, aber trotzdem ist so dieses Angestelltenverhältnis oder Arbeiterverhältnis, dass äh
definiert eben deren Sicht auf diese Gesellschaft. Während das eben bei der FDP, zumindest so äh mittelständische und äh äh selbstständige einfach eine größere Rolle spielten
Nun ist es ja so, dass eben mit dem Internet und das drückt sich meiner Meinung nach hier jetzt auch in dieser Wortmeldung aus. Wir blicken jetzt auf eine,
gesellschaftliche Veränderung, in der das Netz Möglichkeiten bietet, mit ganz neuartigen Fähigkeiten,
ja, man spricht immer von Networking und so weiter, ähm sich auch Lebensmodelle zu zimmern, was ich ja hier im Prinzip mit der Podcastrei,
auch probiere, ja? Und wo man auch, sagen wir mal, so einen, so einen, so einen persönlichen Freiheitsbegriff für sich selber entwickelt hat, dass man sagt, ja, ich will das auch alles selber gestalten und ich will auch ähm,
Da meine Möglichkeiten nutzen, weil in dem Moment, wo ich mich in so ein äh Abhängigkeitsverhältnis zu einer Firma gebe, ist es halt mit der Kreativität,
schwierig, ja? Nicht nur, dass mir dann eigentlich nur noch meine meine Freizeit bleibt, um das zu entwickeln, äh bisweilen ist es ja auch so, dass Jobs auch.
Ähm,
Grenzen aufzeigen, was ich tun kann. Ja, ich darf jetzt keine Projekte machen, die äh den Geschäftsbereich der Firma betreffen, ne. Ist ja auch ein nachvollziehbares Argument, aber auch das äh schränkt einen natürlich ein. All das,
Kommt jetzt quasi auch noch mit rein, weil eben in dieser Internetwelle ist das eben auch wiederum ein eine riesige Chance und da ja eben auch nicht jeder äh problemlos, also da da.
Sich abzeichnet, dass nicht jeder von uns irgendeinem Job in irgendeiner Firma unterkommen wird in Zukunft, nimmt eben diese Patchwork-Arbeitsgesellschaft
weiter zu. Ist die Frage, wer macht sich jetzt hier zum Anwalt dieser Interessen? Weil gerade, was,
Insofern gutes Thema, ja? Alterssicherung und so weiter betrifft die Modelle, die es eben für Selbstständige gibt, sind äh in Deutschland einfach ein ein Witz. Ja, also wenn man sich das anschaut, wie äh Angestellte und besonders Beamte.
Abgesichert sind, wie viele Modelle es da gibt, wie viel Übertragbarkeit von angesparten äh Rentenbeiträgen. Es gibt wie viel Inklusion für Familie und Kinder, et cetera. Da ist was bei Selbstständigen einfach,
nicht in dem selben Maße da ist und das, obwohl du noch ein viel höheres Risiko eingehst, ne, weil bist du mal krank,
ist halt alles vorbei, ja? Und ähm et cetera und das das muss auch ein Thema werden.
Also es absolut, ist ein ist auch ein ganz wichtiges Thema, weil diese Freiheit natürlich, deswegen ähm spricht man da ja trotz,
teilweise sehr guten Einnahmen, die Personen, die so leben, erzielen ja von so einer prekären Situation, in der sie sich befinden, also
Wie gesagt, es gibt da verschiedene Blickrichtungen drauf, ja. Man kann sich als die digitale Bohem sehen, die ähm da, wie gesagt, da so ein Freiheitsbegriff entwickelt. Man kann aber eben auch sagen, man ist die ganze Zeit prekär beschäftigt. Man hat überhaupt
man verzichtet quasi auf diese ganzen Arbeitssicherungsmaßnahmen, die so einen Arbeitnehmer genießt, ja, wenn ein Arbeitnehmer mal einen Arbeitstag oder ein Projekt verdirbt, dann wird der noch lange nicht gefeuert,
aber wirklich als ähm als.
Ich-AG als als Selbstständiger in für irgendein Projekt angeheuert wird und das vergurt, der wird halt nächste Mal nicht mehr angestellt. Und wenn da jemand anders kommt und das gleiche Projekt für günstiger anbietet, das heißt, da,
wird auch so eine Entsolidarisierung der
der der Menschen findet da natürlich in diesem Bereich statt, weil die ja dann alle so konkurrieren und dann gibt's riesige Probleme, gerade wenn Leute da anfangen, schreiben die immer viel zu niedrige Angebote. Ich habe ja auch eine Zeit lang äh durchaus so,
verdient, dass ich also weiß ich in Projekten beteiligt war als selbstständige Person,
und dann äh mir da irgendwie was aufgebaut habe und da verdient man natürlich auch nicht schlecht bei. Also wenn man das, wenn man das vernünftig hinkriegt, dann kann man sich da kann man sich da ganz gut ähm handeln. Aber man hat eben absolut überhaupt gar keine äh,
sicher Altersvorsorgensicherung oder so.
Weil eigentlich verdient man nämlich, eigentlich verdient man nämlich doch nicht so gut, weil man einfach diese ganzen Folgekosten, die eben in einem normalen Arbeitnehmerverhältnis schon eingepreist sind, äh so eben gar nicht sieht und äh an der Stelle wird's knifflig.
Genau, da äh sich darum mal zu kümmern, ist durchaus eine Forderung, die äh über also auch ein Problem, um das sich schon viele Menschen jetzt auch,
äh ihren Kopf machen, ja.
Und ist deswegen auch erstmal ganz schön, dass offensichtlich unter diesen sechshundert Internetnutzern, die dann da in dieses hier gegangen sind, auch jemand war, der sich gedacht hat, hör mal, SPD, ne, mal ganz ehrlich, wenn ich mir das anschaue, wie sich hier gerade die Welt entwickelt, dann solltet ihr euch mal darum kümmern,
Ähm nichts großartig zu Datenschutz und Urheberrecht war zu finden,
Dann gab's noch einen gesonderten Beschluss dieser SPD äh zu Netzneutralität. Da haben sie also auch gesagt, wir wollen grundsätzliche Gleichbehandlung aller Datenpakete unabhängig von Inhaltsdienst, Anwendung, Herkunft oder Ziel.
Und äh diese flächendeckende Breitbandversorgung, wobei mir jetzt nicht so ganz klar ist, wie sich das ernsthaft von dieser Universaldienstverpflichtung äh absetzt. Wahrscheinlich habe ich das nur irgendwie aus verschiedenen Quellen zusammengegotten,
Kommen wir übrigens auch noch zu.
Auf jeden Fall auch noch zu. Ja gut, also das waren die Beschlüsse der äh SPD. Man kann sagen, das Thema an sich fand äh statt. Äh ja.
Also vielleicht abschließend, ja. Entschuldigung, wenn ich dich da so unterbreche, würde man halt sagen, so sie kommen dann irgendwie mit Open Data und äh Mikrokredite für Gründerkultur und Medienkompetenz, ja, aber das wird halt,
Entschuldigung, das wird halt alles überschattet von diesem Vorschlag Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Weil alles, was in diesem schönen Leitantrag Freiheit, Gerechtigkeit und Solidarität da gebastelt werden soll,
das ist alles.
Hinfällig, wenn wir eine Vorratsanspeichung haben, ja, also das ist einfach ein ein, alle diese Dinge, die sie da schreiben, leiden direkt oder äh oder vermittelt darunter, wenn man sagt, jo, alles klar und darüber setzen wir eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das scheint auch in der SPD noch nicht wirklich angekommen zu sein. Also ich meine jetzt wirklich in der breiten Basis, weil ich weiß nicht, hast du hast du das dann gesehen, als das behandelt wurde? Ich habe gehört, dass die Teilnahme zu dem Zeitpunkt,
also zahlenmäßig von Leuten, die sich dann wirklich vor Ort an dieser Abstimmung auch äh beteiligt haben, doch sehr überschaubar war.
Ich habe das also ich habe da nicht den grauen großartig gesehen und konnte das auch nicht mit vorher und nachher ernsthaft jetzt realistisch vergleichen. Da muss ich mich dann auf die Angaben von anderen verlassen, die die die ganze Zeit da vor Ort waren oder.
Also dann machen wir dazu keine Aussage. Ich hatte sowas gehört, aber ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Ja, das das bringt uns zur.
Es bringt uns zu einem Aktionstag, der findet morgen statt.
Genau, morgen schon, morgen, Mittwoch, der vierzehnte Zwölfte, Aktionstag gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und zwar ist es der sechste Jahrestag der Einführung der EU-Richtlinie zu vorherzeitenspeichernd durch das EU-Parlament.
Und ähm da gehen natürlich vom AK Vorrat äh große Aktionen aus und es ist unter anderem geplant, Spinnennetze vor
Abgeordnetenbüros aufzubauen. Ähm das wird in
bisher, ich glaube, so der Stand waren ungefähr zwanzig teilnehmende Städte. In Berlin zum Beispiel auch am Pariser Platz stattfinden. Also wird ein ein deutschlandweiter Aktionstag.
Stattfinden und dieses äh diese Idee der Vorratsdaten speichern soll, also in diesem Fall durch ein Spinnennetz symbolisiert werden, indem äh unsere ganzen äh Freiheiten und persönlichen Daten hängen bleiben. Also wir verlinken mal den Aufruf und,
Wer möchte es natürlich bei diesen Aktionen herzlich willkommen.
Ja und dann war er wieder da.
Der war irgendwie der weiß ich auch nicht was der eigentlich will, aber.
Man schaltet dann irgendwas ein das Internet oder den Fernseher und dann steht Grinsebacke wieder vor einem. Herr Gutenberg, der ist irgendwie nicht sein lassen kann und immer noch davon träumt äh wieder zurück.
In den politischen Zirkus zurückzukehren.
Es ist, ich bemühe mich da jetzt um Ruhe, wahrscheinlich viele Leute, die mich irgendwie kennen, kennen auch irgendwie meinen Stand, meine Position zu Gurtenberg. Ähm.
Also ich habe fassungslos dann eben festgestellt, dass äh Nelly Cruise
Ich sag's jetzt mal Cruise, weil in verschiedenen Bereichen Hollands wird dieses OE vielleicht auch mal gerne als Ö ausgesprochen, aber ich kenne Bereiche, in denen das eher als U ausgesprochen wird und ist also eine niederländische,
EU-Kommissarin von der Volkspartei, vor Freiheit, in Demokratie,
Äh und die ist für die digitale Agenda EU Kommissaren seit zweitausendzehn, war davor äh Wettbewerbskommissarin.
Und die hat jetzt gesagt, sie möchte also die äh wie heißt das Antidisconnect, ne? Antidisconnect-Strategie, hat sie das genannt, oder?
Tut mir leid, dass ich das ist. Ich bin immer noch so no disconnect. No dis Connect Strategie. Äh starten möchte, um,
den arabischen Bloggern zu helfen. Ja, das ist wieder schön, diesen arabischen Frühling wird dann da.
Glorifiziert.
Absolut glorifiziert, obwohl dieses Thema jetzt auch inzwischen durch war, dass dieser arabische Frühling jetzt nicht unbedingt großartig stattgefunden hat, weil die Leute Internet hatten. Ähm aber okay,
äh
Arabische Frühling wird dann gollorifiziert und wird gezeigt, wie wichtig das war und ähm in Syrien wurden Massaker für Monate geheim gehalten, aber heute hat jeder ein Handy und kann damit wie ein Journalist arbeiten,
Und deswegen äh muss, wenn friedliche Demonstrationen geplant werden, die Menschen müssen dann kommunizieren können. Und das hat sie sich jetzt auf die Fahne geschrieben und dafür braucht sie einen externen Berater, der ihr da hilft mit seiner Expertise und seinen Talenten,
und das ist Kuttenberg. Ja, also Gutenberg, vielleicht kurz zu zu Erinnerung, ja, ich hatte da.
Einzige Politiker, der derzeit nicht gerade total beschäftigt ist.
Also Gutenberg hat für die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gestimmt, hat das sehr groß auch auf Abgeordneten seine rationale
erklärt. Gutenberg hat, als es um Netzsperren ging, ja? In seinem inzwischen legendären Auftritt äh in der ARD, da die
ähm Teilnehmer an der Online-Petition sehr unmissverständlich in die Nähe von ähm Kinderpornografie, Verteidigern, Fürsprechern oder Befürwortern gebracht, ja. Gutenberg ist verheiratet mit ähm,
Dieser ähm also Tatort-Internet. Ich muss nur dieses Tatort-Internet, was hatten wir bei Tatort-Internet? Nee, RTL zwei Sendungen, ja, mit mit Stefanie von und zu Gutenberg,
die sich da profiliert hat als äh Vorsitzende des Vereins Innocence in Danger, von dem
Keine Sau jemals etwas gehört hatte, der nicht irgendwie eine Pressemitteilung oder sonst etwas gemacht hatte. Ja, aber sie war langjährig verdiente Aktivistin in diesem Verein, der zum Schutze der Kinder.
Irgendwie im Internet da tätig ist und diese diese Sendung war ja also dieses Tatort-Internet, da hatte sie noch diesen Udo Nagel dabei,
Also auch eben so ein völlig umstrittener Typ. Ähm der irgendwie auch mal in der Politik drin war,
und ich glaube Innensenator in Hamburg oder so, ich habe das in einem Artikel auf Netzpolitik dann auch mal nochmal zusammengefasst ähm,
hatte sie auch noch dabei und hat ja diese unsägliche Sendung gemacht, in deren sie irgendwie mit Lokvögeln da in Online-Foren unterwegs waren.
Und irgendwelche Männer angesprochen haben und dann irgendwie denen erzählt haben, man wäre irgendwie,
ein junges, hübsches Teenager-Mädel und man hätte irgendwie Lust, sich mit denen zu treffen. Und dann haben sie diesen Personen aufgelauert oder oder haben sich dann mit denen getroffen, haben die dann da gefilmt und dann da irgendwie online losgestellt. Und,
Aber das war ja anonymisiert. Wir hatten ja irgendwie so ein Unkenntlichbarkeitsmachtding vor vor ihren
Köpfen hat aber nicht lange gedauert, bis die ersten dann auch tatsächlich identifiziert waren in ihrem Dorf, weil man natürlich die Häuser erkannt hat und die äh Fahrzeuge und die Restaurants und die äh also eine unsägliche Sendung
Eine ganz klare Propaganda gemacht hat so für Vorratsdatenspeicherung eine Beteiligte an dieser Sendung, diese Beate Kraft Schöning hatte sich ja dann auch da ganz klar ausgesprochen dafür, ähm,
Echtzeitmonitoring und äh unter anderem eine ein Gesetz gegen Groaming, was es aber etwas, also ist quasi dieses äh wäre also das Flirten eines erwachsenen Menschen mit einem.
Teenager,
Dass das also schon unter Strafe gestellt wird, wobei das, glaube ich, eh schon irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie da der tatsächliche Sachverhalt war. Da stand, glaube ich, eh schon, weil auch war auch vorher nicht legal. Und ähm,
Tatort-Internet schützt endlich unsere Kinder. Ja, also das ist die Ehefrau
dieses äh Menschen Gutenberg, die das natürlich nicht aus eigener Initiative irgendwie, weil das jetzt irgendwie das Thema war, um das sie sich völlig frei ohne irgendwelche Absprachen mit ihrem Ehemann
interessiert hat, sondern selbstverständlich, um da eben politisch irgendwie Schützenhilfe äh zu bieten und dieses.
Dieses Traumpark Gutenberg da irgendwie,
zu inszenieren und dann das, also die Sendung hat dann nachher auch ähm Rügen bekommen, allerdings keine offiziellen Mahnungen von den Medienwächtern. Ähm.
Aber es war äh das war wirklich so eine der eines der eine der ganz großen.
Sachen des letzten Jahres in politischen Inszenierungen so, also auf jeden Fall in den Top ten. Was ich da noch vielleicht ganz kurz, kann ich da auf die ähm
Artikelserie bei Netzpolitik ORG, verweisen. Dem Thema hat sich dann der Jörg Olaf angenommen.
Jörg Olaf Schäfers, der äh leider auch in diesem Jahr gestorben ist, aber da also sehr ausführlich wie es so Jörg Olafs Art war, sich mit dem Thema,
auseinandergesetzt hat. Das werden wir dann auch verlinken und hat da also auch sehr großartige Recherche zu betrieben, diese Serie,
wer sich, wer sich da nochmal so richtig aufregen möchte, kann da guten, alten Jörg Olaf Style bei Netzpolitik Org nachlesen.
So, jetzt habe ich mich, äh jetzt habe ich mich schon irgendwie in diesen in diesem Tatort-Internet verloren.
Naja gut, aber ich meine, das sind ja das sind ja wirklich so die entscheidenden äh äh Dinger, die man auch einfach an der Stelle beachten muss
in der Einschätzung, um wen es sich jetzt irgendwie handelt. Ich meine, wenn er jetzt irgendwie so irgendjemand wäre, der bisher da,
vielleicht wenig Profil hätte aber zumindest Goodwill, ja, nur auch dieser Goodwill lässt sich ja eigentlich an nichts wirklich ablesen. Ich meine, was
bringt ihnen jetzt äh ausgerechnet an der Stelle äh diese Position. Ich meine, das ist natürlich so fadenscheinig. Jetzt versucht er sich auch noch von diesem Internetmakel.
Zu waschen, indem er dann diese Gegenposition einnimmt. Also ich bin einfach fassungslos,
dass dieser Mensch sich wirklich auch für nichts zu schade ist, also wirklich kein Fettnäpfchen da auch äh auszulassen scheint. Und ich frage mich einfach.
Der einfach jetzt so eine so eine mega, so ein mega ähm.
Geheimbund briefing hat und da eine Strategie fährt mit der er am Ende, von der man irgendwie weiß, äh unter den Auguren, dass das
trotz aller vernichtenden Kritik äh von Leuten, die das schnallen, trotzdem durchkommt oder ob der sich einfach,
Wirklich nur verrennt und und und einfach nur bekloppt ist. Also es ist macht einem wirklich fassungslos.
Also es ist, ja, ist ja relativ offensichtlich, dass dass er jetzt irgendein PR-Strategen hat er da ja. Es wirkt, es.
Keine Brille mehr.
Keine Brille mehr, Haare auf einmal irgendwie halbwegs vernünftig geschnitten und ähm.
Also es ist irgendwie ganz klar dieses Thema Netzpolitik ist einfach gerade das ist gerade das Thema, was man als Shootings da haben möchte, ja? Netzpolitik ist gerade das Feld, in dem du mitmischen willst, wenn du in der Politik sexy sein willst. Und zwar,
so wie in Christopher Lauer, möchtest du da,
Du möchtest Parteitage wie die Piraten machen, du versuchst deine Parteitagsprogramme mit zu machen. Netzpolitik ist grade irgendwie das Ding, was abgeht.
Das, das ist das, das, das, was man haben möchte. Das wollte vorher keine Sau haben und diejenigen, die sich da seit Jahren engagieren, schwimmen jetzt äh zurecht, teilweise auch auf einer Welle
ja? Äh und und kassieren da Lorbeeren für jahrelanges Engagement. Und natürlich gibt's dann auch Leute, die das denn irgendwann, also der
Berufspolitiker in seinem Habitus, er kennt das natürlich und weiß, dass dieses Feld offensichtlich jetzt das gebotene ist, in dem es sich zu profilieren gilt.
Also ist ganz, ganz, ganz, also es ist nichts, es ist so, es eigentlich ist es so offensichtlich, keine Sau, wer darauf gekommen, weil es so absurd ist, dass das ausgerechnet.
Ja, wenn du wenn du das vorher erzählt hättest, so als Vorschlag, so pass mal auf, jetzt kommt er demnächst noch und wird hier irgendwie EU-Kommissar für Internetfreiheit.
Guter Witz irgendwie, gleich mal bloggen und so und, und, und der holt, ich meine, was kommt als nächstes? Tritt er dann irgendwie im schwarzen Hoodie auf mit Sterne und Tastatur,
Ja, also äh.
Er noch beim Kongress vorbei.
Und hält noch einen Vortrag.
Also es ist es ist unmöglich. Es ist übrig. Völlig, völlig.
Völliger Wahnsinn, ja, also wie wie Markus das sehr schön äh äh Markus Beckedal, dass du sehr schön im ZDF Morgenmagazin heute Morgen sagte, das wäre als ähm wäre Silvio Beelus jetzt irgendwie beauftragt dafür äh äh Frauenrechte und.
Die Sexis, wo sind alte Korruption, ja? Also ungefähr so ist das, ja. Ähm du hast ja gerade schon auf Verschwörungstheorien angesprochen, also,
ich meine, eine eine PR-Strategie ist keine, ist nicht direkt eine Verschwörungstheorie. Ähm,
aber es gab natürlich schossen dann auch diese Blogposts in äh aus dem Boden, wo daran darauf aufmerksam gemacht wurde, dass diese Nelly Cruise ja auch die Bilderbergkonferenzen besucht hat,
Sowas äh ich meine man kann lasse ich jetzt unkommentiert stehen, aber man sieht,
äh ich meine, durch so ein solche Sachen, die so absurd sind, die so absurst sind, werden natürlich auch solche Theorien genährt, ja? Und da hat ja am Ende keiner was von äh wenn,
letztendlich da etwas steht, was was auch wirklich so derart unerklärlich ist, dass du wahrscheinlich wirklich dann irgendwann nur noch versuchen kannst, dass entweder.
Na gut, aber man man muss ja auch immer die Chancen äh sehen, die solche Situationen bieten. Bisher war ja der Herr nur äh in der deutschen Politik restlos verbrannt.
Dann hat er sich ja, dann hat er sich jetzt erstmal so in die USA begeben in so einen Schutzraum, wo er dann irgendwie als, wie hieß das so schön, Establish Statement oder sowas.
Äh nicht in die.
In irgendeinem Denkpanzer da herumtrollen konnte, das äh Statement, ja. Na ja, also,
unterschieden hat er sich schon, ja? Das kann man jetzt nicht äh von der Hand weisen. So und jetzt ähm hat er dann ja vor ein paar Wochen auch mal versucht so äh den ersten Zeh in in deutsche Gewässer äh hineinzusetzen.
Hat gemerkt, dass das Wasser noch sehr kalt ist.
Ja äh genau dazu wollte ich noch kurz was sagen. Da zu diesem diesen DDR ersten Zeh da reinzuhalten, ne, mit dem ich glaube nämlich meine,
Meine ähm oder meine Interpretation dieser PR-Strategie, die gerade stattfindet, ist alle alle haben ja gesagt, Gutenberg, viel zu frühes Comeback,
warum acht Monate oder was ist die Sache her und ähm er kommt viel zu früh mit diesem Comeback-Versuch. Meine Interpretation ist, dass er wusste, egal ob er in in acht Monaten oder in fünf Jahren den Comeback-Versuch macht.
Er kriegt wieder auf die Mütze. Er ihn, ihm wischt seine gesamte äh Betrugsplagiats-Nummer, fliegt ihm wieder um die Ohren.
Und das war unvermeidlich. Das war auch durch Zeit nicht abzusitzen. Da hätte auch in zehn Jahren kommen können. Und ich glaube ja oder meine meine Interpretation war jetzt bis zum Montag, dass er,
gezielt das jetzt gemacht hat, um quasi dieses Feuer abzubrennen.
Um jetzt für den Move auf EU-Ebene schon mal Mainz, das war schon klar.
Die Munition verschossen ist, ja, dass alle wissen so, ey, der kommt jetzt hier, will jetzt ein Comic Versuch und sich dann hinstellt und sagt,
Nee, ich so, ich wollte hier nur ein Buch ähm ich wollte hier nur so mein Buch hier mal äh mit dem Giovanni di Lorenzo, mit dem
Chefredakteur des angesehensten Blattes Deutschlands, nur mich um mein Interviewbuch mal kurz so, aber hier also Politik oder so, nee, nee, also du erstmal nicht, halte ich mir offen. Und dann in einem Jahr zu kommen,
Wenn er nämlich weiß, jetzt haben sie alles verschossen. Ja, also so ein so eine so eine Art halt mal irgendwie hoch und lass die mal draufballern,
damit die Kritiker irgendwann keine Munition mehr haben, kommt nix neues mehr. Und das.
Kam aber erstmal was Neues. Kam gleich wieder Good Plug und hat irgendwie ihm auch noch äh nachgewiesen, dass sie bei einer, was war das ein Vortrag, den er gehalten hat?
Ich glaube, da ging auch ein Artikel mit einher, auch wieder vierzehn Plagiate auf zwanzig Seiten oder so gefunden, ne.
Unfassbar, also darauf wollte ich.
Zum Beispiel auch so ein Ding so, lass die Munition mal kommen, ja? Lass das mal hochholen, ja, also.
Okay, äh sehe ich, sehe ich, ja. Kann äh durchaus sein, dass das äh äh alles so ist, wie auch immer
Ich würde sagen, der der Krieg ist eröffnet, ja, also äh man hat ihn einmal so weggeschossen und alle werden irgendwie zufrieden gewesen, wenn er jetzt einfach wegbleibt. Jetzt kommt er irgendwie mit der Nummer,
Jetzt ist irgendwie klar, OK, der Typ, der will Ärger.
Ja, also.
Der will aufs Maul,
Äh da sage ich, kann er haben, ja, also das wird dann nochmal äh ganz spannend. Äh ich denke, man kann sich jetzt hier auch die die auf die,
Durch die Zensursolar, Debatte äh
geschärfter äh und gewachsene Netzgemeinde, ja, die sich in Aktionismus äh unter Einsatz äh einer Vielzahl von äh Mitteln hergenommen hat, kann jetzt mal üben, wie man jetzt diesen Druck auch
auf EU-Level aus äh äh übt, weil das fehlt nämlich ohnehin noch. Das,
einfach generell einfach eine Fähigkeit, die so nicht existiert. Und äh da ist das doch einfach mal ein schönes äh Ziel, ja, wo man ähm
kreativ arbeiten kann, ohne dass es jetzt gleich so eine so eine große Sache ist, die man total äh verkacken kann. Da kann man sich halt einfach schon mal ein bisschen
dran abarbeitenden im Herren.
Also man muss immer vorsichtig sein, wenn dein Gegner sich auf einmal neben dich stellt, ne. Das ist nicht äh also man kann da jetzt als,
erprobte äh Netzgemeinde, muss man natürlich jetzt schon, ist da Vorsicht geboten, ja? Also der wird sich jetzt offensichtlich international positionieren als derjenige, der irgendwie gegen Zensur und sonstwas ist.
Ähm das ist natürlich jetzt also es macht es auf jeden Fall schwieriger, ihn anzugreifen, ja? Also und vor allem muss man sich dann eben auch überlegen, ich.
Bin ja immer ein Freund des Arguments. Und äh ich bin eigentlich auch äh sage immer, dass ich äh dagegen bin ähm wenn das Argument dann dasteht, es davon abhängig zu machen, wer es sagt.
In diesem Fall werde ich eine Ausnahme machen müssen,
Die Frage ist nur, äh wie gut gelingt mir das, ja? Oder stehe ich irgendwann da als der ähm äh derjenige, der das irgendwie atominem klären möchte? Internationale Politik,
finde ich, finde ich jetzt gar nicht so einfach. Also ich sehe das also äh für mich als in meiner ganz klaren Position als äh Gutenberg.
Kritiker, ja, ähm.
Irgendwie klare Position für irgendwie freie Netze, also für mich ist das ein ganz klarer Afro gegen vielleicht sogar mich persönlich, ja? Also ich nehme das persönlich, dass der sich da neben mich stellt, ja? Ähm,
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz ähm.
Man muss da jetzt halt klug handeln. Ich sage ja jetzt auch nicht einfach draufhauen oder so
sondern hier muss die richtige Strategie gefunden werden und das kann auch gut sein, dass das eine ganz andere Strategie ist, als die bisher gewirkt hat, ja? Aber es ist es ist halt einfach zumindest schon mal jetzt so ein schöner Schleifstein, an dem man äh die
die Messer äh wetzen können.
Okay, weil so die.
Uns macht auch noch Spaß.
Wir werden sehen. Also ich äh mir vergeht immer der Spaß, wenn ich so ein leichtes Zittern in der Hand kriege, ja und das bemerke ich in dieser Angelegenheit äh zugegebenermaß.
Ja? Äh vielleicht noch ganz kurz, also das muss man dann auch noch zitieren, es gab natürlich dann große Kritik ähm allen voran übrigens auch Christian Bartz vom Mobis EV, Missbrauchsopfer gegen äh Internetschweren einer einer einer,
Denke ich, eine der wichtigsten Zeichensetzung in diesem Fall in dieser ganzen Sache, dass sich dieser Verein da gegründet hatte, also war auch irgendwie damals die Sache, die oder ist nach wie vor einer der Vereine, die die mich so richtig,
wo ich so richtig so so Gänsehaut kriege, weil ich denke so, Mensch, ey, das ist echt das waren so in meinen Augen die wichtigen. Weiß ich nicht, aber oder sind nach wie vor die wichtigen äh.
Also eine wichtige Vereinigung, die da die es da gibt und äh die eine großartige Arbeit, die da geleistet wird. Ähm hat also auch einen offenen Brief geschrieben länger, wo er das dann auch noch sehr diplomatisch ausgedrückt hat, aber natürlich kocht er also die,
Kritik hoch und auch dann also an Nelly Cruise und man fragt sich, warum? Ja, warum Gutenberg? Ja, es hätte so viele Menschen gegeben, mit denen sie sich hätte schmücken können, ja? Sie hätte irgendwelche
Aktivisten.
Europäische Aktivisten sich da in dieses in dieses Boot holen können und ähm sie wurde dann auch wohl äh fühlte sich dann gedrängt ein äh Blogbeitrag zu schreiben.
Indem sie also sagt,
der der liegt also in einer deutschen Übersetzung vor auf der Seite der dieser Europa Parlamentsblogs Europakommission Blogs, wo sie also sagte, warum hast warum Gutenberg, ja? Und dann sagt sie ähm.
Man muss das jetzt versuchen, mal da so den den.
Tuktus zu treffen.
Den Duktus, ich bin mir auch bewusst, wie wichtig dem Europäischen Parlament die Internetfreiheit als Bestandteil unseres Schutzes der Menschenrechte ist. Allerdings brauchen wir Ansätze und Ideen aus allen Bereichen. Deswegen habe ich Carl Theodor zu Gutenberg eingeladen.
Ähm wunderbar. Sehr schön. Wenn jemand die Macht des Internets versteht und seine Macht die Politik zu kontrollieren, dann ist das Karl Thedor,
das hat er auch selbst schon gesagt. Ja gut, wenn er es selber gesagt hat, okay, wunderbar. Ja, und dann, dann, also, ich meine, man muss.
Nach dem Motto, ich bin ja das populärste Opfer, wer könnte äh könnte jetzt kompetenter sein als ich, ja? Ich meine, es ist natürlich so ein bisschen so ein so ein äh,
LFMF Mime auf einmal, was hier losgeht, so aber.
Aber es wird, es geht ja noch.
Kriegt er uns nicht, ne?
Jeder, der mit Carl Theodor gearbeitet hat, kennt seine politischen Fähigkeiten. Ich habe mit ihm gearbeitet, als er noch Wirtschaftsminister war.
Ich an ihn bewundere, ist, sein frischer und internationaler Weitblick. Er hat zwei Ministerien geleitet, dessen Aufgaben bei diesem Projekt eine Rolle spielt. Ja, hat stimmt, ja?
Ich weiß, dass er daher in der Lage ist, wichtige Gespräche zu führen und Ideen zu sammeln, um denen zu helfen, deren Rechte offline und online beschnitten werden. Also,
Völlig skurril. Äh es geht dann wieder um diese Talente, dann sagte sie ja auch noch irgendwie, ähm.
Bitte anderer Ton fahre ich.
Okay, dass sie stets nach Talenten sucht, nicht nach Heiligen. Also ich, also wie kommst du auf die Idee, wie kommst du, es kann also, sorry, ich meine,
es gibt doch nicht äh man sitzt doch nicht als Europakommisarin da und denkt sich, wen könnte ich mir dafür jetzt ans Boot holen, ins Boot holen? Nehme ich doch mal irgendwie den umstrittenen Gurtenberg.
Also es sorry.
Ja, aber weißt du, was das wahrscheinlich aussagt, ist, dass,
Die Wahrnehmung, die wir jetzt von ihm haben in Deutschland, sich einfach nicht über die deutschen Grenzen hinaus verbreitet hat. Das ist auch das, was ich,
Vorhin schon andeuten wollte, ja? Das ist äh wir wir sehen das jetzt so hier, weil weil wir hier in unserer eigenen äh Wolke sind und für uns kommt das irgendwie
sind komplett fassungslos, ja, aber wahrscheinlich hat einfach diese Geschichte sich einfach auf europäischer Ebene
überhaupt nicht irgendwie niedergeschlagen,
Ja, die sehen das irgendwie ja okay, der ist da jetzt wegen so irgendwas zurückgetreten und äh aber ist doch ganz gespannt. Ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein so ein so ein.
Wäre nicht der Erste, der.
Mehm ja, so was diese Unterstellung, er sei ja irgendwie talentiert oder er sei ja irgendwie toll oder anders oder ein Politiker, der mal was anders macht und so,
woher?
Wo der weggeht, ist verbrannte Asche!
Also ich bin kein Freund der Bundeswehr, ja, aber die sitzen da jetzt und haben die Kacke am Dampfen, weil der irgendwie mal eben äh die Wehrpflicht da äh abgeschafft hat. Ich will jetzt, ich bin kein Freund der Wehrpflicht, alles nicht so, ne, aber äh das hat ja auch äh
der Nachfolger äh ist das noch de Maizire, ne?
Hat ja dann auch gesagt, so, ich mein, der hat ja dann gesagt, also was hier, was ich hier vorfinde in diesem Ministerium, ist der absolute Irrsinn.
Das ist eine Katastrophe. Und die sitzen da jetzt und er hatte also wie gesagt, mir ist herzlich so, wenn ich ihm eins positiv anrichte, dann vielleicht die Bundeswehr ruiniert zu haben, ja, dann würde ich ihm noch gutheißen, aber er war dann auf jeden Fall nicht sein Ziel. Und ähm also
man kann ihm da wirklich nirgendwo Talente oder Fähigkeiten zusprechen
Er hat keinen. Also er hat ein äh politisches Talent im Sinne von äh Leute irgendwie zu begeistern, obwohl er nichts in der Hand hat, ja. Also er aber er hat auch kein, er hat kein Talent für das Politische,
Er hat ein Talent für für RTL zwei. Ja.
S, er ist einfach das das politische Äquivalent zum Heizdeckenverkäufer.
Also das ist.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, was Sie also jetzt vorhaben. Ähm also dieser Gutenberg, ne, Netzsperren und Vorratseinspeicherungsbefürworter äh möchte jetzt sich da in dieser Now-Disco-Strategie irgendwie anstrengen.
Und Internet-Überlebenspakete irgendwo hinschicken und darin soll soft und Hardware,
zur Zensur und Umwachungsüberwachungsumgehung sich befinden. Also, ich meine, die haben wir, ja, die ist ja auch Open Source größtenteils, also ich meine, das zentrale Ding, zentrale Software in dem Bereich, die da zu nennen ist, ist natürlich Tor, das macht direkt beides und kitzensur und Überwachung,
ähm kann man sich frei runterladen.
Wird. So und dann hätte man, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Jacob Eppelbaum, den wir hierher auch bei Logbuch Netzpolitik schon erwähnt hatten und wenn man sich zum Beispiel den dazu geholt hätte, wäre das ja auch ein Schritt, wo man echt applaudieren könnte, ja?
Sagen, ja Mensch, super. Ähm Problem ist natürlich, dass Tor ja auch in gewissem Maße äh deutsche netzsperren,
Deutsche Vorratsdatenspeicherung umgehen würde. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie fänden die das, wenn wir das hier einsetzen?
Wie finden sie es, ja? Dann äh wollen sie sich dafür anstrengen, was ja jetzt.
Wir hatten ja gerade das Thema, kein Export von Überwachungstechnologien aus Europa heraus. Steht da so schön?
Heraus, ja. Ähm
ich frage mich, was also wo soll sie dann noch also aus welchem Grund soll sie dann in Europa noch hergestellt werden, wenn sie nicht da herausexportiert wird? Ich meine, ganz klar soll sie hier auch angewendet werden. Okay, das ist dann offensichtlich eine eine andere Stelle und dann hat sie noch den Vorschlag gemacht, dass man ja auch
Hosting Unterstützung bieten könnte. Ähm für,
Dissidenten in unterdrückten Ländern. Da könnte man also dann deren Webseiten hosten. Okay, ähm ist eine Idee, wo auch schon jemand anderes drauf gekommen ist bisher. Also es gibt in den Bereichen, die sie da jetzt ansprechen, nicht unbedingt so einen großen Bedarf, ja?
Was was vielleicht 'ne interessante Sache wäre das hat ja Hillary Clinton auch gemacht und das jetzt auch ich weiß nicht genau wie lange das her ist, dass sie ihre,
Es war da glaube ich ihre erste oder zweite Rede zu wo sie dann einfach gesagt hat, zack, wir geben jetzt hier Kohle rein. So und die haben dann halt einfach äh an ähm an Tor und sowas gespendet, ja? Und stellen denen dann da,
Kohle zur Verfügung
mit denen die dann ihre Arbeit machen können, ja? Ich meine, das sind, da machen selbst die äh macht selbst die Amerikaner eine bessere Politik. Aber jetzt demnächst hier das das äh
Internet-Überlebenspaket von Gotenberg. Ich glaube, dass damit kriegst du auf eBay echt eine Menge Kohle, weil das das wird einfach der Scherz. In jedem Hacker-Space.
Steht dann gerahmt, das Internetüberlebenspaket von.
Ja, also ich glaube, die EU-Kommission bräuchte eher mal politische Care-Pakete, um da irgendwie das äh Überleben noch zu sichern. Im einundzwanzigsten Jahrhundert, wie auch immer.
Ich meine Hände zittern immer noch, aber wir müssen jetzt.
Wir müssen jetzt hier mal äh ein Ende äh finden, die äh Latte der einen Stunde ist äh gerissen worden.
Es ist jetzt auch, glaube ich, erstmal alles gesagt. Wir haben den Eindruck, das Thema wird uns noch eine Weile erhalten bleiben und äh ja. Ansonsten eine Sendung haben wir noch in diesem Jahr. Dann gibt's die verdiente Weihnachtspause.
Machen wir eine Weihnachtspause oder machen wir was vom Kongress?
Dass ähm das werden wir dann noch äh äh sehen. Ich halte das für möglich. Er ist Eidergack. In diesem Sinne, sagen wir tschüss. Tschau tschau.
Tschau, tschau.